Oh Micro has of course long been a
champion of dignified old-fashioned
labor the kind where you get dirty but
that doesn't mean he is closed-minded or
reverse to new technologies in fact his
new show returning the favour' is one of
the biggest things on Facebook
impressive talent runs in his family as
well micros mother Peggy has a brand new
book coming out tomorrow
it's called about my mother true stories
of a horse crazy daughter and her
baseball obsessed mother Mike and Peggy
Rowe join us tonight and we are grateful
they are here Peggy as you know your
husband is a folk your husband your son
is a folk hero on this show beloved by
our what was he like when he was younger
oh god you won't believe it but he was
very shy really he was he was in fact
when somebody would come to the front
door sometimes he would just dive under
the kitchen table or into the hall
closet and he was a neat freak he didn't
want to get dirty so I was gonna ask you
what's the most embarrassing thing but I
think you already you already told us he
drove into the hall closet how did you
get him out
well when the people left he came out
great now the headline tomorrow is Mike
Rose mom explains how he came out of the
closet thanks doctor
awesome job I knew I knew I could get it
my skill is an interviewer is that story
in the book mrs. Rowe not in this book
but it's in my next book have you read
this book Mike read it I wrote the
foreword to it and honestly you know
what makes you awesome last time I was
on your show we were talking about good
news and I said the next time I'm
bringing my mother and you said go ahead
and you meant it so I'm sitting here
with my mother because she's written the
ultimate book of good news this is she
been writing me stories for years I
started reading them on face book
publishers fell in love with them and a
book popped out and this is a book 19
stories about growing up next to her
mother my Nana and the two of them
together absolutely nothing in common
loved each other dearly for 70 years and
this book in these times and my humble
estimation Tucker and I don't want to
overstate it mom and I don't want to
gild a lily in front of you but this is
the balm our country needs you heard it
from me BA LM absolutely believed that
no and I'm I'm sincere this is exactly
what we need and I I would say and all
of our viewers no matter who they voted
for what they think no matter who they
pray to our fans of yours and now of
your mom's how long do you take you to
write this mrs. Rowe well I've been
writing it for years actually I have
written several stories over the years
and published them in newspapers and
magazines and the response was so
positive people loved a feel-good story
and yeah they're true and so I decided
to write some more and put them together
in a book you want the true story Tucker
yes she comes home from Macy's one day
and says you'll never believe what Nana
did I said what happened she said well I
was pushing her in a wheelchair and she
saw an Orioles Jersey she was crazy for
the Orioles she leaps out of her
wheelchair takes off her blouse puts on
the Orioles Jersey my mother has a heart
attack says mom what are you doing
Nana says nobody cares I'm an old woman
in a bra right then she knocks a
mannequin over the head falls off rolls
down the aisle people start scattering
mom comes home and says Michael I think
the time has come to write a book about
your grandmother so Nana was not hiding
in the hall closet when people came over
she said it sounds unbelievable but
every word was true that he just said oh
by the way everything the ROE family
tells us we take at face value you were
the most believable people we know and I
hope you'll both come back and congrats
on the book god bless I'm getting it
tonight no joke oh and by the way one
good turn deserves
their mom picked this up today and she
can't put it down ship of fools my
country don't make you sad it's great to
see you both thank you very much thank
you for happy well appreciate the